I might, I might even see seems to have use as a nontoxic chemo therapeutic agent that can
shrink tumors. That being said, there are many studies that say it doesn't work. What's your
experience in understanding? It didn't, didn't cutters couldn't do this at one time. I also understand
that life was somal. Vitamin C can achieve IV levels of vitamin C in your bloodstream. Can this
replace IV vitamin C? What's typical protocol for IV vitamin C and or liposomal vitamin C? We're
reducing tumor size by tone of 10,000 and now has two IV therapy clinics. Okay, last part of
the question. First, yeah, please IV therapy clinics are copied up around little tones even so
that's kind of nice. What's not nice is the cost it still can be anywhere between 150 to 250
dollars to do a session of IV vitamin C. First part of the question, IV vitamin C seems to have
nontoxic chemo therapeutic effects, but there are many studies that say that it doesn't work.
Well, I just wrote a blog just the other day and it's titled Is Research Real or Biosolone
because if you read my book, you realize that there's what's called publication bias.
Publication bias in research is not to hold on this point to this research piece many studies say
and it doesn't work, but publication bias is very real. That means like if a drug company is trying to
get a drug pass, they will actually put study out to dozens and dozens of places, universities,
independent doctors, my sister-in-law worked for a neurologist who was not literally never into
her clinic that all she did is make money ready in studies. And she my sister-in-law just sat there
and had these epileptic patients coming in, some of them got a placebo, some of them got the drug,
and then she would have to meet with them on a weekly basis and she'd have to write out any side effects
symptoms. She had a fill in this form that was produced by the drug company and she would
that's the neurologist just made both those buckles running these studies and never even showed up
and work. A nice gig, I guess, huh? And then the problem is is that so the drug companies will get
these, you know, let's say 50 studies back after six months of running this drug study and let's say
out of the 50, let's be worst case scenario, 45 who showed ill effects and it didn't work,
patients didn't get any better. Matter of fact, they had all these negative side effects,
but five of them showed slight improvement. They'll only publish the best two studies. The rest
of the 48 just don't ever get published. So in a very real sense for medical literature, for any data,
for any statistical clarification of the efficacy of a drug, those studies never happened. The only
ones that happened are the one or the two that got published that could have been extremely skewed
because the doctor slash university or wherever whoever sent the results back wanted to continue
to make money from Pfizer. So they skewed the results in their favor so that they could keep money
pouring into the system. That's I mean, you think, oh, you're cynical. I'm not sitting. This is just
the truth. So it's just what goes on. So if a drug company wanted to slander, you know, a nutrient
or vitamin C or, you know, anything like that, they'll just run a study. A number of years ago,
they ran a study on vitamin E in the heart. They purposely used alpha to clot for all, which is
outermost shell in the vitamin E, which everybody knows. That's not the protective part of the
vitamin E. Vitamin E has four outer shells to crop orals in and four inner total triadls. That's
what makes up a whole food vitamin E molecule. Well, they used only that outer shell alpha to crop
for all as the as this in the study. And it showed that people who were taking that
form of vitamin E for their heart actually did worse. So then this giant study and all these
articles and CNN reports said vitamin E is bad for your heart and any nutrition that's telling you
to take vitamin E for your heart is a quack and blah, blah, blah, blah. They just purposely skewed
the study. It's just it's unbelievable. And if you haven't been awake during the last few years of
COVID, how they just absolutely just ruined the lives and careers of doctors and people that have
been trying to help people with Ivermectin and other other natural aids or viruses, you need to
you need to open up your eyes to see what really goes on. So I'm not trying to be cynical. I'm just
trying to be an honest observer of what's going on in our times. So I'm all for looking at studies,
but you have to look at them with a very critical eye. That being said, I don't believe that vitamin C is
going to work on everybody else. And I do believe that there's a lot of alternative things out there that
are skewed in the favor of an alternative thing too. In fact, somebody asked a question down here
that we'll get to in a second. This next question, oh, it's the next question that this person
is thinking about going to this clinic that says that they have documented success of 90 percent
remissions. Boy, that would send a red flag, a nine flag call right away, that they're even able
to to make a statement like that, even if it was true. They have to be very careful
of these types of statements. This is what gets alternative doctors in trouble. And I think it gives
us a bad name as well. When you start making claims that that it's just how do you define that,
you know, it's where practice of medicine has a five-year survival rate, which creates rubber
numbers. It sounds because if you live one day after the five years of after diagnosis,
you're considered cured, even though you might have lived a horrific life and died the day after
that five year. So you're pushed in the list is cured, which is very, you know, skewed data. So it's
really hard to truly keep data on what is the true remission. Because I feel like I've been
remissioned, but I could have cancer growing in time right now, and I could go into a full blow
reoccurrence at any given time. It's a day by day dealing with things. So I get it, and you just want
to make the best decisions, and you're trying to do your research to make the best decisions. And
what should I do with IV vitamin C, and should I go to a clinic like this who's touting pretty high
success rates? It's very difficult to make decisions when you're trying to deal with something that's
affected your life. Let's get back to this question. I'm able to learn. I think IV vitamin C can
be very helpful, but I don't think it's a cure all end off for everybody. And if it's something that
you want to try, I'd say by all means, try it. There really is no downside to vitamin C.
So by all means, give it a try. Can you use liposomal vitamin C in lieu of IV vitamin C? Yes,
it no. You'd have to take a lot of liposomal vitamin C to get up to an equivalent dosage of let's
say 75 grams of IV vitamin C. So typically, if you're going to go in for IV vitamin C, you start out
at a lower dosage in that lower dosages, and then your weight, maybe 15 to 20, maybe even 25 grams
in your first sessions. And you slowly work up to 35, 50, and you slowly work it up to 75 by
pencil people for over 100 grams of vitamin C. Now, it would be really difficult to get equivalent
dosage of 175 grams of vitamin C doing liposomal. I guess it still be a lot less expensive,
and if you don't have a place around you to go, you could still possibly do that.
Dosage of liposomal vitamin C, it's typically said that one gram of liposomal vitamin C is
equivalent to about five grams of IV vitamin C. I don't know. That was statistics from several years
ago. I don't know if that's still thought to be true. But if you could use that type of
measurement to try to figure out if you're going to get the same dose. The benefit of doing liposomals,
you could do it daily versus it's going in once or twice a week doing IV. And then the IV, you might
get this major therapeutic benefit flush dosage, but then it has a half life in your body and it's
going to be gone. So you say, well, maybe that's better. You get this major flush, and then it's
flushed out, but maybe, but maybe it would be better if you had just a little bit less dosage on a daily
basis. So I think it's really worth experimenting with each person. Everybody might be different
to how they respond to it. Some people might respond better to a super high dose once a week. Some
people maybe are medium dose in liposomal on a daily basis. It's worth experimenting with.
I'm not saying you don't look at research. I'm just saying that you look at it with a critical
eye. And I think you should look at everything with critical eye. Yeah, I just think that's the world we live in.